a concerned mother Timothy rakes I'm not
Timothy Timothy that's it that's sort of
the amalgam that's the androgynous name
of Kimberly and Timothy no Kimberly
rakes the founder of a parental rights
group at Iowa Mama bears just showed up
to a school board meeting at Ankeny High
School
and she was she referred to this insane
incident that occurred at the school
where the gay straight Alliance Club the
sort of LGBT propaganda Club at the high
school invited drag queen performers to
to perform for the kids for their
end-of-year meeting and so Kimberly
rakes shows up wearing the outfit
that the drag queen wore take a listen
ing
then it should because this guy walked
into our school doing it
can you dress up
this is what this is what the man
dressed like in front of our kids so
this makes your head spit this pisses
you off in any way shape or form it
should because I'm embarrassed to stand
here in the outfit that I am in today
but I have a point to prove in that is
that this outfit should not be ever
accepted in our stores anywhere ma'am
please please put that that out for that
that's obscene that's pornographic that
belongs in a strip club
right
right that that's true
so why can't why can a why is it wrong
for a mother at the school so someone
who's in the school Community a woman to
show up wearing women's clothing
that's kind of scandalous and risque
that's unacceptable ma'am sit down
please change put some clothes on
but when a dude like a big fat pervert
dude who has no connection to people at
the school shows up wearing the exact
same women's clothing that's wonderful
that needs to be celebrated that's so
great why is it that transgender people
or drag queens or any of these confused
men why is it that they get to do
whatever the hell they want and that is
wonderful and celebrated
why is that
that doesn't make any sense at all
and the woman I thought she made a
beautiful point
and even for us I think even we've
become kind of desensitized to it oh
there are those weird drag queens again
well it's like the joke and Family Guy
where there's the transvestite sitting
in a bar and the bartender comes up and
says ma'am you can't look at pornography
You Know download pornography at this
bar and he dressed up as a woman says oh
no no I'm transgender and the bartender
says oh okay then you can do whatever
you want right why is that why do but
you see the woman you're like Whoa man
that's weight that's way too sexual to
be around kids that's totally
inappropriate right it is
how much more inappropriate is it for
some weirdo dude to show up and prey on
little kids like this of course anyone
any adult who had any foreknowledge of
the drag queen event needs to be fired
from the school for sure and then the
this club the gay gay straight Alliance
certainly needs to be disbanded at this
high school if if not at other high
schools as well and we just can't we
need to take a much harder stand on this
because the radical LGBT activists are
never going to stop until we are all
wearing the rainbow flag the radical
LGBT activists are not going to stop
until you and everybody else
are waving the rainbow flag mark my
words how do I know this because of poor
Jack Phillips
You Know Jack Phillips
his case his cases have made it to
courts around the country all the way up
to the highest court in the land
Jack Phillips has appeared on this show
he's the owner of masterpiece cake shop
he is a really nice soft-spoken Earnest
Christian guy who was asked to create
cakes specifically for a gay wedding
quote unquote and he said oh I'm sorry I
can't participate in a gay wedding
because I'm Christian and so you know
you can go to there's a gay cake shop
down the street the honors are super pro
gay stuff and so they'll it's no big
deal you just go down there it'll be
fine and what happened the radical LGBT
activists sued this guy and tried to
destroy his business
unfortunately he was able to win that
case
but he said he wasn't saying I won't
serve customers who have eccentric
sexual views I won't serve gay guys who
come in to buy a cake but he said I I
can't make a cake specifically for your
gay wedding I can't you can't force me
to use my art my craft to participate in
a ceremony that I consider to be sinful
and contrary to my religious views there
are plenty of other cake shops that will
do why are you guys so focused on making
me kneel down and worship at your altar
and why are you so
interested in making me violate my
Christian views when there were so many
other options for you because it's not
about the cake and it's not about the
wedding it's about making the Christians
get down and do what they're told right
that's that's what this is really about
and the way you know this for certain is
that after Jack Phillips took a huge
financial loss really hurt his business
but he he prevails in court
well he's in court again
is the activists are going after him
again because after his Supreme Court
victory
he gets a call from a woman quote
unquote it's really a man named Autumn
scardina who calls Phillips
and requests a birthday cake that had
blue frosting on the outside and pink
frosting on the inside to celebrate his
gender transition
and he says
obviously here we go again you know you
know that this wasn't about the cake
there are plenty of other cake shops but
this radical trans activist calls this
guy to say oh we didn't beat you last
time we're going to beat you this time
make celebrate my sexual delusion
celebrate it do it do it now bigot
you're gonna do it you stupid Christian
we're gonna make you do it we're gonna
use the force of the law and so he's in
court again I hope he wins I don't know
it I it's totally up in the air this
poor man at first before I met Jack
Phillips I thought is this guy just is
he a political activist who's really
just trying to put himself in these
situations and
he's not he's ju he's just a soft-spoken
nice Baker who keeps getting targeted by
these vicious people these vicious LGBT
activists who obviously hate Christians
and don't want to allow Christians to
practice their religion and and just are
they're so confident in their sexual
identity that they demand that every
last person in this country
affirm their way of life and their
delusions that's how confident they are
that if even one person even thinks like
um I actually don't think you're really
maybe totally a woman even one person
thinks that that's a that's an
existential threat we've got to bring
Jack Phillips to his needs
they're not going to stop and so
everyone's going to try to find some
Middle Ground like oh well you know
actually let's just support we can
redefine marriage in this way but not in
this way and let's just go halfway and
look we can I'll refer to Caitlyn Jenner
as Caitlyn because you can change your
name but I don't know if I'm willing to
I don't that only at a certain age are
you willing no guys guys it's not
there's no there's no middle ground here
on questions of ultimate truth and like
ontology and I'll just quick basic
questions of the of being and human
nature you've got to just pick a side
and stand for the truth Kanye can do it
why can't you
why can't you because you think oh well
we'll meet halfway okay I'll bet what if
I bake a cupcake I'm not going to bake a
full cake but a cup no that's just not
either Christians get to practice their
religion or they don't either men are
not women or men can be women I these
are there's no middle ground here okay
you've got to just pick a side and have
courage
and just take a lesson from Yeezy okay
I've been told this is shocking to me
some people disagree with things that I
have said and there is a tick tocker who
has disagreed with something that I have
said so informed my producers this
morning they informed me of this fact so
we will be going over it on the member
block and of course we'll be going over
because it is Friday the rest of the
mailbag questions so the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
oh
foreign